for those of you listening guys i knew
steve in college
and um his nickname was
mr mayor which i think you even had in
high school a little bit
um and i don't know how to explain it
guys like so we went we went to duke
university in in durham north carolina
and
it's a it's not it's six thousand
undergrad is like ten thousand
with with grad school kids it's
relatively big um but everybody knew
glonis
and it was because of these random he
was always doing a different venture and
the big one was
uh throwing parties in college there's
spartan entertainment and he was known
for
wednesday night shooters night which
shooters is a famous bar at duke it's
like a western themed bar and it's a
piece of crap
but wednesdays nothing was going on and
stephen's like well look if i can get
people to show up on wednesday and they
pay five bucks at the door can i get a
cut that sort of thing i'm pretty sure
that's how it started so
talk to me about your
entrepreneurial journey because to me i
always like to consider myself a natural
builder but
nowhere near it seems like it was in
your dna probably even younger than
college i imagine so tell us about you
and your background a bit
yeah it's funny thinking back to the
spartan entertainment days but
you know in many ways when people ask me
what you know i majored in at duke like
i say entrepreneurship we didn't have a
major for
business or entrepreneurship there but
that's what i did
you know that that that's what i spend
my time doing and you know for those
that
didn't go to duke between uh 2006 and
2010
um this was a really interesting age
where facebook was brand new
um you know zac and i were the first
grade
of college students that actually had
facebook for throughout the entire
day of our college experience and back
then you had to have the
edu address to even uh get onto the
network so i remember
uh you know when i was a senior in high
school people would like
apply early to a safety school and put
the deposit down
just to get the edu address so they
could join the facebook at the time
it was that pretentious and exclusive it
was a big freaking deal
and um one of the things that you know
we
noticed that was really different from
for people like zach and i
versus any other generation that had
ever gone to college was that we had
this thing facebook
and we were connected with every single
person that we met in
in many ways like we're still connected
right like you know all those people you
friended from your freshman year dorm on
facebook
you know they've been following
everything that you've been doing with
your charity with you know with the yang
campaign
so in many ways like we had this
built-in distribution network
and we kind of came along at the right
time back then
bar owners were not able to be on
facebook so
back in the day when you know you
created a facebook group and people
joined and you created an event and
people showed up
uh me and a guy named zach maris who's
another
uh entrepreneur who was a senior when i
was a freshman
and is now the ceo of a very successful
tech startup back in durham called
teamworks
zach and i had the idea to start
throwing
non-affiliated parties because while
zach and i were friends we were in
different fraternities so
if sigma nu was throwing a party the
delta 6 would show up
if the atos were throwing a party the
saes wouldn't come
but zach and i decided to create our own
branded parties that were unaffiliated
and slowly but surely everybody started
coming so it didn't matter
what fraternity you were in it didn't
matter if you were in a fraternity it
didn't matter if you were
in band or a football player like you
came to our parties
and um and over a four-year period we
took
starting with one event which was uh
putting beer pong tables out
uh on wednesday night at like the big
bar on campus that used to be closed and
offering three dollar pictures
and taking the cover charge um we ended
up having over
17 000 college students in this facebook
group
and started a variety of businesses uh
off this key asset so we had a college
boxes
business for a couple years we had a hot
dog stand at one point
uh we did dj equipment and t-shirt
rentals and
venue bookings like you name it zach and
i were doing it
and i think it really gave us uh our
first
taste of entrepreneurship and for zach
you know that capital from spartan
entertainment was a lot of the seed
money that started his business and he's
continued to do that uh today and like i
said it's a very successful business
and for me uh this you know taste of
entrepreneurship was something that i
could never
fully get out of my mouth and when i
ended up leaving durham
and going to be a trader for a few years
and working at linkedin
like i did other cool things but that
entrepreneurial
bug kept you know kept nagging at me
and i really believe that like the three
percent of people
on earth who have that mutation in their
brain that makes them like a true
entrepreneur uh it's almost impossible
for those people to
to do great like the best work of their
lives if they're working for somewhere
out someone
someone else and i would put myself in
that case
and uh and for me you know cameo has
been something that's really
at that guy point for me ikigai is this
japanese philosophy
that believes that your true life's
calling is the intersection of
what do you love to do what are you
great at what does the world need and
what can you ultimately get paid for
and it has to be at that like pure
intersection point
and you know zach i'll ask you uh you
know you've known me for a long time
like is this bit is is the fact that i
started this business surprising to you
oh dude not not at all um you've got
these
smartest minds in the world in many ways
at duke university
and they're all like
slaving away at their econ exams and
their chemistry exams just
and you're out there throwing parties
which seems like a joke
um but on the other hand you're learning
10 times more like because
like you're negotiating deals and you're
going to contracts and booking venues
and recruiting people and developing a
marketing plan and
like raising capital and like investing
in new businesses i figured i knew like
smart entertainment was like the tip of
the iceberg for you but i was more
surprised when you went i think you were
a traitor and you worked at linkedin and
i was like
i knew that wasn't the end game either
so i was so like um
but i remember getting an email from you
it was a survey monkey survey like hey
we've got this idea
where famous people
can get paid to facetime their fans
what do you think of these names and it
was like this long survey
of a bunch of names uh cameo was one of
them if i recall but there were a bunch
of others
um nothing personal cameo wasn't my top
vote
uh i don't remember what what it was i
probably looked it up but it's fun it's
funny
we were just talking about this survey
and um
cameo wasn't on the original list
actually there were four
there were four and i will tell this is
exclusive nobody else has ever heard
this story
so i hope your listeners enjoy uh we
we hired a branding firm in miami called
vanilla shake who's incredibly talented
and we went through the exhaustive
process of like
naming and in a consumer internet
business like a name is so
critical and when we first started the
business
we we didn't know what the name was so
we were using
um well so there are two things that
happen number one my co-founder
martin uh his family businesses in the
uk are all
barren like barren homes and baron
finance and things like that
so he wanted to call the business baron
app and
they were and and actually today that is
the legal name of the company the legal
name of the company
is baron app inc something tell me when
you guys go public the new york city
stock exchange listing
is gonna bear an app llc
and it's funny because we had actually
never um
we had never nobody's ever like called
us bear an app before but in the wall
street journal
like funding announcement they always
use the legal name of the business
so it was talking about baron app inc
valued at a billion dollars the parent
company of cameo
so it was just kind of interesting and
and but we knew
baron app could not be like what we
called this business
at the time we decided to use a code
name and we called it uh power move
so pow it was called project power move
was was
was basically what we called it in the
branding firm that we hired came up with
three names uh first was hero hub
uh so almost like it was like a hub to
find your heroes
the second name was thrillo and the
third name was hyped
i can tell h-y-p-d bunch of dudes are
making this this company
we put this name out these four names
out
to all of our uh followers on
linkedin we collectively downloaded all
of our linkedin contacts
and put the survey monkey out and
unfortunately power move
won so we knew we didn't have a great
name
and some of the feedback the branding
firm personally had recommended hero hub
and for our east coasters everyone
felt that that sounded like a sandwich
shop which was
you know kind of funny uh so ultimately
we you know went back to the drawing
board and my little brother
who was working for us at the time was
like i think it should be called
cameo he's like these people are kind of
making a cameo
in your life and immediately it was like
thank you little bro
that has to be the name of course
cameo.com was not available
and seemed to be impossible to get
uh all the social handles weren't
available
so what we decided to do is we bought
book cameo
verb in front of it it made all of the
socials book
cameo for a while but for the first
couple years of the business
maybe people just thought it was called
book cameo so that's
so that's a a little you know fun story
about
how cameo got its name
[Music]
you